retour en salles de rédaction pour la
suite du 19 20 vendredi de deuil et de
colère en roumanie
requiem pour les martyrs de la
révolution hurlements contre les
communistes du gouvernement mais rhein
gorbatchev choisi la voie de la
discussion face aux problèmes des
nationalités le numéro un soviétique a
promis plus de liberté aux ligues
seniors qui parlent pourtant des
manoeuvres politiques
air france décolle pour jouer dans le
ciel des grands la compagnie nationale
rachète 54% de ut à et affermi ainsi son
contrôle vers un père mais d'abord
l'albanie ayant depuis 1944 cultivait
jalousement le culte du marxisme
léninisme intégral la petite albanie a
toujours intrigué l'occident alors
aujourd'hui après la chute de tous les
régimes communistes d'europe de l'est
des regards inévitablement se tourner
vers tirana vers l'albanie où les
voisins yougoslave y croit pouvoir
affirmer ce soir qu'il se passe quelque
chose
d'après l'agent ce livre cela faisait
nhung l'état d'urgence aurait en effet
été décrété dans tout le pays l'état
d'urgence ou en tout cas des mesures de
surveillance extrêmement sévère pour
éviter tout soulèvement populaire les
explications de jean claude perpère la
sentinelle de staline l'albanie serait à
son tour touchée par le souffle de
liberté qui viennent balayer les régions
de l'est sur les organes de presse hugo
slaves les autorités albanaises depuis
plusieurs jours ont renforcé la
surveillance des zones frontalières avec
la yougoslavie et la grèce les habitants
de ces régions ne pourrait plus circuler
d'un village alors dit
ce soir on apprend que l'état d'urgence
à être décrété après de vives
manifestations se seraient déroulés dans
la ville de shkodra dans le nord du pays
selon un quotidien politika yougoslave à
tirana même la capitale la police
contrôle étroitement la circulation
automobile et la garde a été quadruplé
autour des résidences du président ramiz
alia convient de voir neiges mère ocha
veuve du fondateur de la république
informations bien sûr démenti par les
autorités albanaises
toutefois il semble bien qu'une partie
des 3 millions d'habitants est embrigadé
coupés du monde depuis 50 ans commence à
soulever
le joug de la dictature impitoyable
imposé par un verbe déjà et son
successeur parmi alliera sait déjà il ya
trois ans nash coderre des rebelles
avaient affronté les unités spéciales de
l'armée pendant plusieurs heures avant
d'être écrasé sans pitié aujourd'hui
encore il est probable que ce moment au
moine ni le pouvoir n'hésite aurait pas
pour se défendre a provoqué un bain de
sang reste que les albanais et
l'ambassade d'albanie à paris notamment
à l'instant fait savoir qu'il s'agit là
encore une fois d'une calomnie en
provenance de la yougoslavie qui en est
coutumière dit l'ambassadeur d'allemagne
en france en basse at il précise
également que tout est calme dans le
pays là bas et que les vols d'air france
notamment trois fois par semaine ont été
effectués cette semaine sans aucun
problème
faites moi confiance c'est ce que pétré
romane dans le même temps le jeune
premier ministre roumain réclamer cet
après midi à bucarest aux milliers
d'étudiants qui eux manifestaient pour
réclamer la démission de tous les
communistes encore en place cette
manifestation a pris d'autant plus
d'importance que le nouveau gouvernement
aujourd'hui contestée avait décidé de
faire du 12 janvier une journée de deuil
national mai à bucarest
l'histoire de la révolution est encore
loin d'être terminée pour certains
romans en tout état de cause
jérôme cathala minute de silence
cérémonie religieuse dépôt de couronnes
mortuaires
cette journée de deuil national avait
été soigneusement organisés afin
d'honorer la mémoire des morts de la
révolution
même le premier ministre petr et romane
et le président du conseil du front de
salut national assister ce matin à une
messe commémorative
mais peu à peu le deuil le cède à la
colère ont brûlé carte de membre du
parti
on lance des slogans
anti-gouvernementaux et surtout anti
communiste à bas le communisme
les communistes dehors la foule en fête
réclament le départ des instances
dirigeantes du pays
d'anciens responsables du parti
compromis avec chercher ce coup les
quelques soldats qui essaient de
s'interposer sont débordés place de la
victoire devant le siège du comité du
front de salut national c'est le premier
ministre roumain en personne qui doit
s'expliquer qui essaie de convaincre le
parti communiste n'existe plus long
style aux manifestants donnez moi une
chance cette fois la foule s'est
dispersée mais ce type de manifestation
pourrait bien se multiplier et pendant
ce temps là l'homme par qui la
révolution est venue en europe de l'est
continuent de se bat
dans son propre empire pour lui éviter
l'éclatement mehal gorbatchev a
poursuivi aujourd'hui sa mission en
lituanie et à son habitude et en bon
joueur d'échecs le numéro un soviétique
a avancé des pièces maîtresses plus vite
qu'on ne pouvait l'imaginer
ces propositions pourtant été accueillie
avec scepticisme par un peuple lituanien
qui parle de manoeuvre politique
la partie d'échecs est donc loin d'être
finie rémy gullit celle de stratégie
politique oblige la constitution de
l'urss est aujourd'hui au coeur de
toutes les tractations entre gorbatchev
et les républiques socialistes tenté par
l'indépendance en décembre dernier les
députés lituaniens abroge l'article 11
qui barrait la route au multipartisme
hier soir devant des intellectuels
lituanien mikhaïl gorbatchev est allé
encore plus loin en sortant de l'oubli
l'article 72 autorisant chaque
république fédérée à se séparer
librement de l'urss
pour le numéro un soviétique la
stratégie est ambitieuse mais très clair
il faut à terme créer une nouvelle
fédération soviétique où les républiques
qui le désirent deviendront totalement
autonome ce soir pourtant cette dernière
proposition est déjà contestée par les
nationalistes lituaniens leur slogan
gorbatchev veut gagner du temps jusqu'au
prochain congrès du parti communiste
soviétique en octobre là il proposera
avec des réformistes une nouvelle
politique centraliste mais en aucun cas
l'indépendance pour la lituanie mereiles
gorbatchev at il a battu avec l'article
72 ses dernières cartes diplomatiques
alors qu'il poursuit son voyage en
lituanie la lettonie voisine vient à son
cours aujourd'hui de compter contre le
rôle dirigeant du parti communiste est
l'exemple balte est observée
attentivement par toutes les républiques
frontalières jusqu'au kazakhstan en
géorgie les manifestations nationalistes
sont quotidiennes dans le caucase et
atterrit au sud s'affrontent très
violemment avec les arméniens eux mêmes
en conflit direct avec le soviet suprême
un peu partout donc de l'est à l'ouest
l'intégrité de l'union est menacée par
la complexité des relations entre
peuples peuple à nations et tribus
dans les pays baltes gorbatchev est
confronté à une opposition déterminée
avec mes empreintes de maturité
politique
s'il échoue dans ce contexte la
dislocation de l'union soviétique
pourrait se faire plus imminente sans
que personne n'en mesurent les justes
conséquence ce qu'il faut encore savoir
de l'actualité de ce vendredi en europe
de l'est et dans le monde
jean paul girouard
hans modrow cède à la pression de la rue
le premier ministre est allemand a dû
renoncer à la création d'une nouvelle
police politique
son projet avait déclenché une levée de
boucliers de l'opposition et même de
petits partis de la coalition
gouvernementale des grèves de
protestation ont éclaté et des dizaines
de milliers de manifestants se sont
rassemblés dans plusieurs villes du pays
aux cris de pas de nouvelles têtes
compromis sur le problème de la minorité
turque en bulgarie une table ronde
présidée par le nouveau dirigeant
pétards mladénov a confirmé le droit
pour les bulgares musulmans de par les
turcs et de garder leur nom d'origine
pour apaiser les nationalistes des
garanties ont été données pour le
respect des droits des bulles guerre de
souche dans les régions à majorité
musulmane columbia a récupéré le
satellite de 10 tonnes
ld ef où ils devaient être ramenés sur
terre par challenger en 1985 il était en
quelque sorte abandonnées dans l'espace
depuis six ans
la moisson d'expériences scientifiques
il renferme va pouvoir être exploitées
tuée la semaine prochaine
air france prend 54 et demi pour cent du
capital de la compagnie privée ut à part
ce rachat au groupe privé chargerait ça
air france renforce aussi son contrôle
d'air inter et voici la compagnie
aérienne nationale en passe d'acquérir
la dimension de ses grandes rivales
étrangères
un rachat spectaculaire qui au delà du
domaine économique pourrait bien
relancer politiquement cette fois la
police la polémique sur ce qu'on appelle
les nationalisation rampante
les explications de pierre babey
sur le tableau de bord du nouveau groupe
quelques indicateurs chiffrés la taille
tout d'abord l'ensemble air france chuté
à air inter constitue la deuxième
compagnie européenne 6,15 milliards de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires tout juste
derrière british airways un clignotant
orange ensuite en dix ans la part de la
france dans l'ensemble du transport
mondial est tombé de 4,7 à 3 5%
même constat sur le marché européen sur
100 passagers les compagnies françaises
en transportait 18 ans 79
elle n'en transporte plus que 14 10 ans
après c'est dire que ce rapprochement
c'est tout d'abord un retour sur terre
un atterrissage sur une dure réalité
séparer les deux compagnies n'ont pas
les moyens de se livrer une guerre
fratricide et suicidaire sur des marchés
de géant
aux etats-unis par exemple où les majors
compte souvent trois fois plus
d'appareils que le nouvel ensemble
or ut à air france se disputaient autour
des pistes de new york boston miami mais
reste à décoller à prouver maintenant
que un plus un plus un ça fait plus que
trois les compagnies françaises ne sont
pas réputés pour leur productivité
il ne faudrait pas confondre croissance
et embonpoint
sinon gare aux surcharges en juin 88
l'un des tout premiers airbus a320 d'air
france s'écrasait au cours d'une
démonstration à habsheim en alsace eu
trois passagers mouraient dans la
catastrophe
erreur humaine ni inculpation de
l'équipage quels avaient été les
premières décisions de l'enquète or
voilà que madame marchionne le juge
d'instruction de mulhouse veut réunir
une nouvelle commission d'experts cette
nouvelle commission devait en fait se
réunir ce soir mais il semble très
difficile de trouver des experts
acceptant d'en faire partie il faut dire
que cette contre expertise pourrait tout
simplement mettre en accusation l'avion
plutôt que lé pilote une affaire dont on
reparlera à l'instant j'apprends que
dans la bresse du village de jaar ya un
certain nombre de paysans en colère sont
en train de défoncer la route et se
prépare à passer la nuit sur place
leur but est d'empêcher la création
d'une décharge ajar ya une décharge de
déchets nucléaires enfin un échec comme
malfaiteurs perceur de tunnels à
gardanne près de marseille
voici le tour de france de l'actualité
préparer comme monté par marie-odile
panijel
le casse aurait pu réussir mais les
malfaiteurs étaient vraiment trop
bruyant
en creusant un tunnel pour accéder à la
salle des coffres du crédit agricole de
gardanne il était parvenu jusqu'aux murs
de soutènement de la banque
lorsque le système d'alarmé de l'agencé
déclenché à cause du bruit la berceuse
les gangsters ont réussi à s'enfuir et
et libération en fanfare d'un détenus
basques espagnols isidro garage des
bedialauneta arrêté en 85 purgeait une
peine de cinq ans de prison pour son
appartenance à le terrain militaire pour
l'accueillir à la sortie du centre de
détention de muret une délégation venue
de son pays
premières biologiques et casse tête
juridique des triplés qui n'en sont pas
damien est né le 1er 11 jours avant ses
deux frères devant ce cas étrange la
mairie du mans a préféré inscrire sur
ses registres la naissance de jumeaux
précédé d'un frère aîné
les parents eux se battent pour que soit
officiellement reconnu leur triplé
une grande vedette ce soir sur l'a3
vladivostok la ville et le grand port de
l'extrême orient soviétique
constitueront à 23h la dernière étape de
notre série documentaire sur la
pérestroïka au fil du transsibérien
mais dès 20h35 et bien vladivostok sera
déjà plein écran sur l'a31 avec thalassa
pour la première fois depuis octobre
1922 une équipe de reportage en effet pu
pénétrer dans cette ville littéralement
coupés du monde depuis près de 70 ans la
diva stock base secrète soviétique mais
aussi ville symbole c'est le thème du
reportage exclusif d'isabelle moeglin et
jean michel belletante à dix mille
kilomètres de moscou au fin fond de la
sibérie le terminus du transsibérien une
gare dans laquelle aucun étranger ne
pénètre lagarde vladivostok cité
interdite en zone militaire
dans ce port du pacifique isolé du monde
depuis près de 70 ans
une brèche s'est pourtant ouverte un
grand souffle de liberté sied tant
engouffré liberté d'action nous avons pu
filmer seul et sans contrainte la ville
et ses habitants
nous avons notamment rencontrer vladimir
ce docker nous a présenté sa famille
nous a raconté sa vie il ya moins d'un
an
c'était interdit
liberté d'opinion tous les soirs sur la
grand place plusieurs dizaines de
personnes se rassemblent elle revendique
la démocratie il ya quelques mois cette
manifestation aurait été sévèrement
réprimées aujourd'hui la milice la
sphère liberté d'expression sous toutes
ses formes du rock résonnent dans la
maison de la culture lénine de
vladivostok des danses sexy font même
leur apparition dans cette citadelle
militaire du bout du monde
ce soir 20h35 sur l'a3 la mer monte
thalassa la mer monte à vladivostok à
21h30 le retour d'arsène lupin et puis
bien sûr soir 3 à 22h30
présentée par marie gilbert tout de
suite la météo complète de florence
klein maire fut bonsoir il ya demain
très bonne soirée 3